one of the thing - Arena Boyle known for
is the TV series Merlin isn't it I don't
think
and fire was famous I think just a few
people know I am but that one's really
sweet and everyone's like you know and
it's nice of people actually I'm like
something to do and it's nice that
people kind of a like with Merlin people
genuinely adore the show and adore their
stories of it and that's really
important and that's nice when you can
actually do something in there and you
know make super happy when you know
that's the whole point of doing it that
people like what you do and you can yeah
I'm only going over the last eight
months I'm not good what do you what are
you even doing in that time riding
horses having sword fights getting lost
in forests getting really drunk
yeah both in character number you
enjoying it as much as you enjoyed all
the other series yeah cuz have you
watched it it's good fun oh yeah you
know everyone's everyone's really
[ __ ] cool that's all very chilled and
they're all really nice people to work
in Bradley and Colin and Tom and it's a
really nice group of people Pence's its
way it should be it's fun
you